Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain a South Korean fantasy comedy film
called “The Dude in Me.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
The protagonist of the film is the heir of the
Hanho group and a well-known elite gangster,
Pan-soo. In the beginning, we are introduced to
his lavish lifestyle and loveless marriage to
Seo Yeon. Pan-soo only married her because her
father Mr. Han is the President of the Hanho
group and an influential man. Seo Yeon is rich
and spoiled and hasn’t worked a day in her life
but she still feels entitled to her husband and
father’s money. She complains that her father is
refusing to buy her a gallery that she really
wanted. Pan-soo ignores her ridiculous demand
and goes on about his day. In the office, he
is informed of a carpenter who is refusing to
evacuate his shop that needs to be destroyed for
Pan-soo’s next project. To get the job done, he
invites his right-hand man Mr. Bang and asks him
to get the carpenter out, one way or the other.
Meanwhile, the carpenter, Jong-ki is nervous,
knowing that the thugs will use force to make
him evacuate. His fears become reality when
Mr. Bang comes to his shop and threatens to
cut his arm off if he doesn’t sign the papers.
With no way out, the poor man gives up his
shop. In the following scene, we are introduced
to Pan-soo’s business rival Mr. Yang. The two meet
at a restaurant and get into an argument about
business. It is evident that Yang is only looking
for the right opportunity to murder Pan-soo and
take over his business. The next day, Pan-soo
decides to go to an old ramen shop that used
to be his favorite restaurant back in the day.
Alongside him, a high school student Dong-Hyun is
also enjoying the noodles. Dong-Hyun tries to pay
but finds out that he forgot his wallet.
When he apologizes to the restaurant’s owner,
she forgives him and claims that Pan-soo
will pay for him out of generosity.
The gangster is outraged by the bold
lady but doesn’t mind paying for the kid,
even though he ate four bowls of ramen. The
shop owner promises to give him a special gift
in turn for his generosity. A while later,
Dong-Hyun is on the edge of a two-story building,
trying to retrieve a shoe from a pole. As he tries
to reach for it, he loses his balance and falls
on top of Pan-soo who happens to be standing right
below. When Pan-soo opens his eyes again, he finds
himself on a hospital bed. A young nurse calls him
a student and talks to him informally. Confused,
he walks outside and is horrified to see his body
lying down on another hospital bed. Before he can
react, the carpenter Jong-ki launches at him,
calling him his son. A confused Pan-soo looks
into the mirror to finally realize that he has
swapped bodies with the shy kid from earlier.
Coincidentally, Jong-ki, who he threatened to
kill the previous day, is Dong-Hyun's father.
When Pan-soo acts differently than his normal
self and refuses to recognize his father,
the doctor declares that he has something called
Retrograde Amnesia. Pan-soo then recollects what
the restaurant owner told him earlier and runs to
meet her again. However, by then, the restaurant
is being closed and the woman is nowhere to be
found. Meanwhile, his rival Yang hears the news
about him being in a coma. He is over the moon
and plans to take advantage of the situation
to kill Pan-soo. At night, Pan-soo returns home
to his wife who thinks he is an intruder. He tries
to explain the situation but Seo Yeon calls the
security and makes them kick him out of the house.
He is then taken to the police station and
accused of trespassing. His poor father is
distressed because of his outrageous behavior.
Thankfully for him, the police let Pan-soo free
without much fuss because he is underaged.
In the following scene, Pan-soo tries to wake up
his body that is in a coma. Desperate to get
his body back, he jumps on top of Dong-Hyun.
Just then, his right-hand man Mr. Bang enters
the room and stops him. Pan-soo tries to make
him understand that he is trapped in a kid’s body
but Bang thinks he is bluffing and kicks him out
of the room. After being disrespected by his
employees, Pan-soo returns to Dong-Hyun’s home
with his father. The place is too small for his
liking but he has a hundred more problems to tend
to. Jong-ki cooks him a plethora of dishes to
accelerate his recovery. Initially, Pan-soo says
that he doesn’t eat like a glutton but a while
later, the plates are all empty. He realizes that
even though his mind is different, he is still in
Dong-Hyun’s body which affects his appetite.
Jong-ki believes that Dong-Hyun was bullied into
waking on the edge of the building which resulted
in the accident. The next day, he goes to meet his
school principal. When asked about bullying, the
principal claims that nothing of such sort happens
in their school. Pan-soo sees through his lies
and is determined to find out what exactly caused
the accident. As soon as he enters the classroom,
a group of boys make fun of him and flip him off.
Pan-soo instantly registers that Dong-Hyun was
an introvert who was made fun of all the time.
During the lunch break, a girl named Hyun-jung
is also being bullied by popular kids. They
mix her food with a cold drink and make her
eat it. Eventually, they dump the entire plate
of food on her. Pan-soo calls them out for it,
angering the leader of the bullies, Tae Wook.
Before Pan-soo can showcase his fighting skills,
the teachers arrive and Tae Wook has to retreat.
After school, the bullies stop Pan-soo again
and try to intimidate him. In turn, he slaps
them all with zero effort and simply walks
away. Later that day, the bullies trouble
another guy in the washroom. Just then,
Pan-soo comes out from a stall and helps the
poor guy. He also takes Tae Wook’s phone away,
promising to return it the next day. The bullies
are so scared that they let him do whatever he
wants. While going through the phone, Pan-soo
sees a video of the day the accident took place.
It is revealed that Tae Wook and his group had
bullied Dong-Hyun into getting on the edge.
They are the reason he fell off the
bundling and their bodies exchanged.
The next day, Tae Wook’s leader is beating
him up for giving Pan-soo his phone that
has the video on it. Pan-soo arrives and kindly
asks the leader to never trouble anyone again,
blackmailing him with the video. The bully
has no way but to agree. Somewhere else,
Pan-soo’s wife Seo Yeon takes advantage of her
husband’s comatose state and starts dating younger
men. Pan-soo’s rival, Mr. Yang gets a hint of this
and blackmails her into joining hands with him.
The two, together plan Pan-soo’s downfall.
That night, Pan-soo goes to the hospital and
meets Mr. Bang. He tells Bang everything about his
past and proves his identity. The following day,
Hyun-jung bumps into him and drops her stuffed
toy. He follows her behind to return it and
happens to meet her mother, Mi-Sun. To Pan-soo’s
utter shock, Mi-Sun is his first love who he left
to marry his current wife. He calls her by her
first name which surprises Mi-Sun. After Pan-soo
runs away, he remembers how he and Mi-Sun used to
spend their days together when they were young.
When he meets Hyun-jung the next time, he takes
some of her hair to use for a parental DNA test.
The results come out and Pan-soo finds out
that Hyun-jung is actually his daughter.
Following that, he goes to meet Mi-Sun and subtly
asks her about her life. She tells him that she
raised Hyun-jung all on her own because her father
was not a good person. Pan-soo feels awful that
the people he loves had to go through so much
because of his absence. Somewhere else, his
current wife Seo Yeon goes to her father with fake
reports of Pan-soo misusing the company’s money.
In reality, she was told to do so by Pan-soo’s
rival Mr. Yang. Her father believes her and
starts to consider removing Pan-soo from the
company once he gets out of the coma.
Somewhere else, Pan-soo goes to a gym
to lose weight and to get closer to his
daughter who is learning self-defense in the
same institution. Initially, she is skeptical
and is about to leave but Mr. Bang pretends to
be the instructor and convinces her to stay.
Starting that day, the father and daughter train
together and begin getting along well. Eventually,
Pan-soo loses weight and gets fit. The girls in
the school, including the bullies, are surprised
by his new persona. During the lunch break,
Hyun-jung’s bullies stop her again. But this time,
she teaches them a lesson and defends herself
efficiently. The other students are stunned to
witness her newfound confidence. That evening,
Pan-soo goes to Mi-Sun’s restaurant again.
While talking, she mentions her former lover
who she wishes she should have killed. Pan-soo
realizes she is talking about him and chokes on
water. Mi-Sun is helping a perverted customer when
he touches her inappropriately. An enraged Pan-soo
asks her to go inside and fights the perverts.
Mi-Sun suddenly stops him, inquiring why he
is acting out of character. Pan-soo sits her
down and finally tells her everything about
switching bodies with Dong-Hyun. Initially,
she doesn’t believe him but Pan-soo challenges
her to ask him anything that he would know.
When he answers all the questions correctly,
Mi-Sun is in shock. Still, she asks him to go
away from their lives as he did all those years
ago. A flashback shows us young Mi-Sun and Pan-soo
meeting for the last time. He rudely informed her
that he was getting married to his boss’s daughter
and asked Mi-Sun to forget him. The following day,
a popular guy from the school named Minho invites
Hyun-jung to his birthday party. Hyun-jung, who
has never been called to a party, excitedly agrees
to come, unaware of Minho’s actual intentions.
After that, Pan-soo and Mi-Sun meet at a
restaurant where she bluntly tells him that she
doesn’t want him in their lives. He tries to win
her over and kisses her in front of everyone. The
people around them are shocked because to them,
Pan-soo is half of Mi-Sun’s age.
She pushes him away and slaps him in the
face. Still, Pan-soo doesn’t stop and follows her
outside. Suddenly, he gets a call from his friend
who informs him about the bullies’ plan to trouble
Hyun-jung at the party. Pan-soo quickly rushes to
the party and arrives there to see Minho pouring
a bowl of alcohol on Hyun-jung. Angered to see his
daughter crying, he fights all of the guys who are
surrounding her. The girls who witness the fight
fall head over heels for him. Hyun-jung also takes
a stand against Minho and kicks him into the pool.
After that, the father and daughter leave. The
following day, Mr. Bang informs Pan-soo that
his wife is conspiring to remove him
from Hanho's list of potential heirs.
Pan-soo writes a letter to his father-in-law Mr.
Han and asks Mr. Bang to deliver it to him.
Later that day, Pan-soo is walking down the street
when one of the girls from his class asks him
out. He claims that he doesn’t date schoolgirls.
Right after, Hyun-jung arrives and asks him the
same question. Horrified, Pan-soo tells her that
he can never date her and walks away. At home,
Mi-Sun also finds out that her daughter wants
to date her father. She orders Hyun-jung to
stay away from him. At night, Pan-soo’s rival
Yang breaks into the hospital to kill Dong-Hyun.
Just as he is about to do so, Dong-Hyun wakes up
out of the blue. Startled, Yang runs away. After
waking from the coma, Dong-Hyun finds himself
in a strange body and runs to his father.
Jong-ki thinks he is an intruder and is about
to call the police when Pan-soo returns home. He
explains everything to Jong-ki who is still
skeptical but agrees to believe them.
Following that, Pan-soo asks for Dong-Hyun’s
help to solve things with Mi-Sun. The two go
to her restaurant and pretend to have returned
to their own bodies. As Dong-Hyun apologizes to
her as Pan-soo, Yang and his men come to the
restaurant. He had followed Dong-Hyun from
the hospital and is here to kill him once and for
all. Dong-Hyun cries, begging them for his life,
surprising Yang and his group. Pan-soo
sends Mi-Sun and Dong-Hyun to another
room and fights the thugs. But this time, they
have come prepared for his attacks. Suddenly,
Mi-Sun comes out and opens a gas cylinder,
threatening to blow up the entire place. Yang
and his men have no choice but to run away.
Because of the chaos, Mi-Sun finds out that
the guys were lying earlier. Still, she
talks to Dong-Hyun as Pan-soo and tells
him about the hardships she faced because
of his absence. The two hug in the end.
Somewhere else, Mr. Han has found out that his
daughter lied to get her husband in trouble
and hide the fact that she has an extramarital
affair. Han disowns her and refuses to give her
an inheritance. He also asks Pan-soo to
meet him instantly. Since Pan-soo cannot
go in front of them himself, Dong-Hyun goes
in his place with a microchip in his ears.
The chip works fine for a few minutes but when
Han asks him about his second family, it turns
off. With no one to communicate to, Dong-Hyun is
alone to make Pan-soo decisions for him. He says
that after returning from the hospital, he has
realized that family is the most important thing
in the world. Hence, he is removing himself
from the Hanho group to be with his family.
Han respects his decision and lets him go.
When Dong-Hyun returns to the car,
Pan-soo hugs him, thanking him for doing the
right thing. But their happiness doesn’t last
long when an enraged Seo Yeon hits them with
her car. Pan-soo is severely injured and has
to be taken to the hospital. As he is talking
to his family on his deathbed, Dong-Hyun falls
unconscious. In the following scene, Pan-soo is
in an operation theater. His surgeon is the same
woman who caused the body swap. She asks him if he
liked the gift and changes him back to normal.
Six months later, Dong-Hyun, in
his own body, returns to school.
Everyone respects him and is nice to him. He
and Hyun-jung have started dating. Meanwhile,
Pan-soo has bought a better place for Mi-Sun to
run her restaurant. All of them, including Jong-ki
and Mr. Bang, work for her as employees.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.